both j-lo and a-rod were able to address
breakup headlines head-on
but were their kids blind-sided a source
tells e.t
the children definitely want them to
work things out they've grown to be so
close and they are all hoping for the
best
we always got along pretty well last
september j.lo's 13 year old emmy gushed
to us
about her blended family and i was like
oh ella and toshi are going to be my
sisters emmy appeared upset the day the
split rumors broke and we're told that
while j-lo and a-rod are still engaged
like all couples they are having some
difficulties
they had been going to therapy last year
to help sort things out
a-rod seemed to jet straight to the
dominican republic where j-lo is
shooting the movie shotgun wedding
and while for now their ideas are still
on
world of dance j-lo's world of dance
is not nbc just cancelled the u.s
version of the competition show after
four
seasons lopez was an executive producer
and once told us
a-rod would kill it as a competitor if
it's love of dance
alex wins